[Music]
yeah
try to understand what you're seeing so
he's grabbing he has spal displacement
so I can't stay
here so I he grabs I move off to
yield and now I
project so to help me make sure is I
actually hold him in place and then
project now I'm going to I can't go here
he's strong there do you see I can't go
there so I go around
there and that puts his elbow up top and
I circle around it lowering his shoulder
and his grip peels off
naturally so y yield
project go inside this grip
here control the elbow as you do it let
him fall I'm not pushing here it'll push
his grip
off I yield and he will fall off and I
follow the elbow
down
yield
[Music]
inside
yeld project
inside follow
over
ready all right so you're making the
mistake that you're going to crank that
off of him you're going to turn
that
[Music]
resist it's not going to
happen okay don't really reach and use
your pinky it's not going to happen so
you project boom don't try to get it off
go right round it you see and then
you're basically doing a wrist lock
right there that opens his grip do you
understand and
now I turn the shoulder down like just
doing
that
so
wom Project
B don't come into this resistance don't
try to move move it you go around
it that'll open his himself to that
wrist lock so let's work that wrist
lock cuz you're not familiar with it so
you can't recognize it but whenever you
do eel the shoulder is always
lower than the elbow and the wrist until
the very end so some of you don't
understand that and you're here and
you're trying to keep it all flat
shoulder elbow wrist and you're try to
lower it I can't it's too strong it's
not going to
happen so
always
control the shoulder it's always lower
than the wrist so I'm going to give you
an attack right
there
so you
understand the
benefit of
[Music]
this
try it appreciating this diagonal on the
arms in Stand kneel when I kneel I'll
bring it more vertical is I get more
height on
it y
J inside
lower up anding his arm not diagonal
this time more up with your body kneel
Drive in your
[Music]
shoulder
shoulder down elbow higher wrist higher
go
[Music]
there no need for the
Big 10 con do you understand try it